taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking welcome taste
buddies to the taste buds podcast
for the first time ever we're doing an
episode without sal volcano he is away
at the moment
and also for the first time ever we're
having an actual
animal that provides food to people
co-host the show with me
chris
chrissy d
the pig the pig is here dude i'm eating
your freaking meatballs and your sauce
dude it's legitimately awesome thank you
now what do you what's the difference
what do you use instead of breadcrumb
well i i'm on a low carb diet at the
moment because i'm trying to lose some
weight so i used arrowroot powder as a
substitute for the breadcrumbs and then
i just added all the seasoning that a
seasoned breadcrumb would have
wow and there you go
what is this hold on slow down she ate
the meatball you liked it i love this
from scratch too do you like the sauce
the sauce is fantastic did you put sugar
in the sauce no no wow dude this is like
the first thing i've eaten all week that
doesn't have sugar in it no dude it
didn't have sugar in it this is pork
from pork ribs so how do you eat it is
there a bone or you just eat it like a
piece i think that piece is boneless
some of them have bones yeah there's a
little bone in the end there you see it
i've never eaten pork rib before you've
ever eaten pork period no dude besides
bacon you never had a pork chop or ham i
had a pork chop for the very first time
on hey babe like what two months ago
really yeah all right we'll try this
let's try it
you think of that
wow
dude the sandwich shop
is gonna be insane
uh i think it's gonna be good like for a
bit to promote the shop i was telling
you like i wanted to take a bite of one
of the sandwiches and then roof it but
now i'm not gonna do that because then
it's like no dude then i'll just get rid
of a great sandwich yeah i know but
you've had the sandwiches and you
enjoyed them too yeah dude i i told you
i [ __ ] my favorite is the tuna i know
you love the tuna dude because it makes
you you think that you're being healthy
dude i've been sitting on your couch for
two hours and you just keep wiping it
down i mean what do i please i don't
know dude something's coming off of you
i'm noticing moisture specks
on the couch and whatnot
justin the camera pimp did you eat your
sauce and pork and
dude
yeah
it to the mic for the customer pimp
delicious 10 out of 10. we went out when
we were in l.a me and pam we went to
uncle paulie's
sandwich shop in l.a and we took a
picture with him we were like oh god i
hope derosa doesn't get mad i saw that
it made me jealous you know paulias he
used to work at broadway comedy club
yeah no he's a good dude yeah he's got
good sandwiches i got upset a little i
was a little jealous but then when you
said best sandwiches i got jealous and
when it said in l.a
yeah
that's why i said specifically dude i
want to try your sandwiches honestly
pimp right weren't they awesome they
were delicious but then i went to
another sandwich shop in la and they
found out i went to paulie's and they
said that guy's a hack the sandwiches
where's the other shop
oh these two kids from montclair they
were in compton i forget their wow yeah
dude it's so exhausting it's interesting
like there's sandwich wars now dude i
mean i love it dude i love it i take
shots at uh at subway and whatever i can
whenever i can you take shots at subway
yeah they'll crush you they have a lot
of
multi-billion dollar company all i can
say is you you let a pedophile when
you're
into your scheme yeah and then and then
look at the camera and say and he looks
like me
i'm the clean jared dude
when they do eventually make a movie
about jared fogle's life you have to
play them you have to play
i want to it's a dual role then i also
play my competitor self yeah competing
with subway with subway yeah and i'll
i'll play i'll play a cold cut that you
put on the sandwich
yeah you can you play the prize pig
that we slaughter and make our
award-winning sandwich out of oh real
quick i've got enough of salvo going on
vacation by the way i'm a little tired
of it myself yeah he was kind enough
though to put the pole up today oh
that's good okay so what is it
we'll we'll get hold on before we get to
it
before we get to it i got a couple
things i gotta i gotta address with the
fans guys
the jorts
aren't going anywhere
and they're not jorts
they're cut offs
just a little fashion lesson for you
cutoffs are kind of cool they're kind of
down south a little punk rock little
ride in the tractor little we're at the
swimming hole
at the rope swing
at the no effects concert
oh the new descendants is out did you
hear it yet that's cutoffs jorts are
midwest
i gotta go to target and buy uh some
generic uh artwork for no no offense
target i love target but you get the
point
no offense to the midwest but there's a
difference between jorts and cut-offs
okay levi's store sells cut-offs they
don't sell jorts all right that's all
i'm going to say about that they're not
going anywhere second although i agree
with the fans they stink
i mean look what you're wearing lemon's
all i love when you wear you're wearing
lulu lemons these are little lemon
shorts kill you
what dude seven dollars for a short but
the quality is worth it seventy dollars
for sure
you dare put those on when great
companies like bear bottom and whoever
else sent us their clothing i wear bare
bottoms all the time too this is who
you're this is who you're dealing with
uh just so you know sponsors this is who
you're dealing with the lululemon
sellout and i love how you wear a fake
sports shirt to make it look like you're
doing physical activity no dude i gotta
get i gotta get back in the gym i gotta
get back in shape i'm lu dude i'm slowly
losing it we talked about that a lot i
don't wanna ruin it because we talked
about that a lot because i also
co-hosted hey babe with you yeah that's
gonna be a treat this thursday yeah yeah
so all the fans just went ugh oh they go
i guess i know what i'm not doing
thursday
uh
speaking of shirts one other shout out
to uh scott hill and the rest of the
boys in the fu manchu band thank you
guys i'm representing today with the fu
t-shirt one of the food t-shirts you
sent me food manchu is my favorite band
in the world
uh i did an interview about them on a
website called meadow metal injection
they caught wind of it was super nice to
drop a line to me
on instagram sent me a bunch of stuff
thank you guys it's awesome man i've
been listening all the vinyl and
everything thank you so much for the
food shirts i appreciate you sending the
fu man shoe shirts i'd like to say that
i love the 1975 so if you hear that can
you please send me some merch because
i've been shouting out to 1975 for five
years and you haven't even favorited a
tweet and i swear to god if you don't
give me anything now i'm going team fu
man shoe band after this and i'll leave
the 1975. and by the way if you bet you
uh scott dm me and said taste buds rules
how cool is that we appreciate you
listening to everybody we really do john
mayer listens to taste buds i know dude
i know musicians across the globe love
taste john mayer if you're listening to
this
why are you listening to taste buds
it no it is a great show it is a great
show because you guys just get so hyped
about food and i'm sitting there and
being like hey man there's people dying
all across the world why are we yelling
about pea soup i know but
uh and thank you last but not least to
all the new fans of my new instagram
show this stefano where i talk about
this atrocity once a week for about one
minute i'll i trash him people love it
dude and i'm going to be starting my
show called debozo
which is about joe derosa aka joe debosa
well we're gonna go on for one minute
each week and talk about what a bozo he
is i don't know what you're waiting for
dude i really want you to do it well i
know while i was traveling but now that
i'm home i'm gonna just think of a good
one and just let it rip all right eat
more pork and i'll tell the people about
uh
episode today's episode the battle as
you know from the title it's cheesecake
versus chocolate cake which cake is
better
you don't like it do you like it what do
you like the pork i feel like you're
skeeving out a little bit i just don't
eat really the pork the sauce do you not
like this you don't like the pork you
don't like it
i don't
i don't eat pork
did you like the pork chop when you ate
it
no no it was cooked fantastic i just
don't like it but so you're not you
don't like it because it's pork
well we have it to pimp then if you said
it was chicken i'd eat it pimp do you
want it i'm good for now jesus christ
guys
your food is bombing on your own do you
not like it no no i like it
i'm just full and hung over i don't need
more how much did you eat did you finish
your plate
i hate
you pigs
you're hungover pimp yeah i'm went out
and drank last night i didn't go out i
just drank and edited last night
we've been so tired dude i took a nap
i've been like exhausted almost kept
this pork in the pot because i was like
what if they don't finish it it's a
waste of pork
and i wasted it on both of you
listen you've said it multiple times me
eating pork is cannibalism
because i
i mean i would eat that right now if i
wasn't positive you have the delta
variance
i don't dude you have the delta burke
variant look how fat you are
damn it
i know i keep trying
here
[Laughter]
all right listen
shouts out shout outs to delta burke i'm
a fan i love doing that
you know what's crazy i'm a fan that was
just a cheap joke no i actually did
um i had a cbs pilot and my mom was
played by annie potts who was in
designing women i love annie she told me
delta burke was such a phenomenal actor
you know what she told me like the way
sitcoms used to run in like the late 80s
early 90s she said there were many many
many times we would be on set
shooting like shooting the show that was
going to come out in three days acts one
and two and act three hadn't been
written yet they were writing it while
we were doing acts one and two and we
would have to learn the lines quickly
and they said a bunch of that show was
just improv or kind of trying to put it
together because that's the way it used
to run back in the day in hollywood
which is insane it's so cool it's so
fascinating yeah i know it's it's wild i
just saw any pots today
in the new ghostbusters trailer it was
great seeing her character back is it
ghostbusters with women again who's who
are those sequel to the original
ghostbusters and all the same guys are
going to be in it they're in it but
there's a new cast of younger people
that are that are obviously going to
take the torch from them who are the new
ones who are the new ghostbusters like
finn wolfhard
it's a family it's basically egon's like
grandkids are gonna take over got it but
uh you can't but they're they're they're
really like teasing out the original
characters got it so the end of the new
trailer it's really cool like
you keep seeing the ad from the first
movie
where they're going we're ready to
believe you remember that ghostbusters
they keep showing that ad and then
finally after the title card comes up
because you're like i want to see the
ghostbusters
the you see the phone ring in the
original firehouse and you see a hand
pick it up and then you hear dan aykroyd
go we're closed wow and i got chills i
was but annie potts is in the actual
trailer
she's talking she was the best standing
point she's awesome yeah she was smoking
dude she's still she's still hot yeah
but in in uh what's it called and um
who's harry crum do you ever see that
yeah yeah where she plays like the tardy
wife she's so hot in that movie holy
[ __ ] the other one like 16 candles or
something like that whatever she's in
another movie she's in a pink something
no she's in she's in pretty in pink
that's why he's the girl that runs the
record pretty in pink yeah yeah dude
you're a movie buff it's annoying yeah
dude you know what you're not what but
i know you're gonna say it you piece of
[ __ ]
all right look today's one of the
reasons he's not buffing i'm not buff is
because of our loves of these two foods
today it's cheesecake versus chocolate
cake which is the better cake uh chris
you will be defending
cheesecake of course dude my last name's
distefano yeah geez
i will be defending chocolate cake
because shock cake is my favorite
dessert that has ever existed what uh
yeah it is and also chris will be
defending cheesecakes because
on more occasions than one
you have
uh confessed to me that you have eaten
an entire cheesecake
yes more occasions than one i have don't
understand dude one time i ate an entire
cheesecake from stop and shop
supermarkets
that's like already pre-sliced into
eight slices i literally got it out of
like the not the freezer like the fridge
area stop it shop in ridgewood
did it have the paper between yes and i
was eating them out of the paper like
without utensils
[Music]
i was going to say were you pulling it
out like like like it's a taco wrap yes
i was eating it like a taco and i was
licking the cheese off the paper sober
sober dude and again once again i
consumed all that with the diet coke to
knock him out
eat the whole thing honestly i'm being
honest because you know pimpus has
witnessed this firsthand i'm the fastest
eater you'll ever meet in your life i
just consume food that's why i eat so
much it probably took dude i'm not lying
honestly joe like 15 minutes and it was
gone and it was the chocolate swirl one
by the way
unless it's pork that one of your dear
friends made then it's just there i
finished my pork i finished
did you like it it was great really it
was great
why because i lost my voice a little bit
no i don't know you just look like a
variant
i have the attire dude yeah
i know i like i like that i like that
all the variants like the next rant's
gonna be like the jet blue variant
that's the one i'm gonna get
uh usually chris on the show we do a
little bit of history before we get into
the battle okay which one of these was
invented first pimpy let's start with
chocolate cake you already have it up
there i would think that chocolate i
would think cheesecake is earlier i
would have assumed chocolate cake but
let's see here the history of chocolate
cake goes back to 1764
when dr james baker wow baker was his
name discovered how to make chocolate by
grinding cocoa beans between two massive
circular millstones holy [ __ ] that's why
it's bakery called that's why he's the
dessert this is the guy that invented
chocolate yeah yeah see that yeah dude i
that's i i he's a hero of
oh mine god did you know it would lead
to this banker
you created baker and this was 1764
before even a country dude look at what
you created
all right so now you're a ex-history
hyena yeah 70 60. 66 is our birth right
1776. 76 excuse me 64. 1764 we were
still being you know pretty you know
pretty much controlled by the british
but independence was brilliant dude okay
cool yeah all right so so a little bit
more history this is right up your alley
when was cheesecake invented the first
cheesecakes are thought to have been
made in ancient greece see i knew it was
and wheat flour pounded cheese and honey
that's all cheese and honey all right
pimp one more thing before we start out
yeah what's the who made well in ancient
greek made the first cheesecake i guess
uh the ancient greeks they man another
doctor look a physician
named egg agamus agamus the greek
physician egamas who wrote a book on the
art of making cheesecake wow
[Laughter]
on how to make cheesecake that's wild
dude because because the thing is i
think dumb oh god sure no because
doctors know like what's going to make
you sick and keep yourself so it's two
doctors
invented both but can you imagine
argamus how much
he got trashed in ancient greece like
socrates was there was like you're
writing a book on what yeah archimedes
had just around that time made the first
elevator and then this guy and then this
guy literally literally was like i'm
writing a book on cheesecake he was the
first guy anybody ever went you picked
you pig dude
oh my god i would you would be
infuriated right if you were a doctor in
this field uh it's just yeah yeah it's
so funny cheesecake contains more than
250 calories and a whopping 18 grams of
fat per slice
you ate how many slices eight eight
that's sixteen hundred plus another
fifty times eight is what four hundred
yeah that's two thousand calories at
least and once
plus eighteen times eight is oh my god
well over a 100 grams of fat
and they said the danger of dessert is
the amount of saturated fat hiding in
each slice well now it's hiding in my
aorta at almost 10 grams
worst desserts for your health
cheesecake
oh my god dude i can't wait to defend it
dude it's the worst worst for your
health but it's the best i think it's
the best tasting and you could do the
most to it listen i'll say this and this
is how we now slide into the debate
usually i love
cheesecake okay all right i got nothing
against cheesecake i love a cheese i
love a cheesecake with a nice
strawberry uh a
natural strawberry syrup on it yeah not
nothing i get hate more than when i go
into a dessert place
or a pastry shop and they have the
separated cheesecake like you talked
about and then the strawberry one is
obviously like came out of a gun in a
factory and it's all it looks like jelly
yeah
i don't like that that's lazy yeah i
think that's gross and whatever well i
like chocolate cake
who doesn't that's what i'm saying
you're gonna get mad at me for saying
this but i'm dude i'm not even trying to
be funny and i whatever you can [ __ ] on
me if you want but maybe you've tried it
maybe you haven't you know the best
piece of chocolate cake i've ever had in
my life is the olive garden
dude google chocolate cake from the
olive garden it's got chocolate chips on
the outside of it it's called something
too like the chocolate some italian name
dude it's so good yes the no not the
black mousse cake the the one with the
chocolate chips on the outside of it
yeah black thai mousse cake the black
thai mousse cake it's is that from the
olive garden well that's but that's
almost like a cheesecake kind of dish
that's moose cake that's not chocolate
cake but it's from the olive garden
right no dude it looks delicious it is
no it is and honestly man i know it's
not about cake at all and again i i'm
not saying i'm not saying i it's awesome
but the pasta from the olive garden
isn't bad that's all i'll say
it's fine it's fine it's not terrible
it's not terrible it's f yes i'd say
they're fettuccine alfredo some of the
best i've ever had i mean just the stuff
this week that you've been saying to me
and we can't really get into it on the
on camera but the stuff this week you've
been saying to me is not actually that
bad it's yeah i mean you know there's
one or two let's just say people in the
world of entertainment yeah
stink the high heaven that you told me
you thought weren't that bad so now that
now this is the first like so now
because we've been sitting in your
apartment now like i can see like where
the anger like you've been sitting maybe
on this couch when i've said some of the
things i've said when i call you and i
yell at people that we know it's right
you know about people that we know yeah
this is why anyway
uh i here's why i like chocolate cake
better than cheesecake number one it's
chocolate
nothing beats chocolate the moist
chocolate cake the sponginess of that
with the with a chocolate ice cream or a
cream cheese icing on it i mean forget
it get out of town but
the other thing that i love about it is
and also it's the ultimate chocolate
dessert the ultimate chocolate dessert
uh and chocolate is the more than a
brownie a cake chocolate cake
brownies are great chocolate cake
crushes brownies just on the lack of
density chocolate cake has an airiness
and a fluffiness to it
brownies are great but they can be very
dry and very dense yeah but brown you
can eat on the go you can bring a
brownie anywhere chunky i can't eat
chocolate cake on the go you would wow
dude i would do your soccer too you
would you would go out with a fork and a
plate and eat chocolate cake on the
streets in here
oh yeah i forgot dude you're a gavon
folks we are open again for the most
part as a country as a globe
start again folks we are open again for
the most part uh finally through what
was a severe lockdown and no matter how
you're feeling about getting back out
there there's no denying this is gonna
be an adjustment okay
the world's gonna get loud and you know
what when the world gets loud you should
be able to get loud back inside your own
ears loud should be in your control and
you're only doing that with some great
earbuds and you're only getting great
earbuds from raycon that's right the
competitive brand of earbud that is a
portion of the cost of these other
brands these schmancy fancy brands that
are out there it's a quality quality
product and it's coming to you straight
from raycon let me tell you this right
now they you're gonna get a bunch of gel
tips for your comfort
unlike some other brands that just stick
right in your ear they're gonna let you
adjust these to your
personal preference uh you're gonna get
a 32 hour battery life so you can listen
to what you want when you want for a
really long time and again we're talking
half the price here of these other
highfalutin brands so create your own
soundtrack don't let the world dictate
it to you with raycon
right now listeners get fifteen percent
off your entire raycon order at buy
raycon.com slash taste buds that's b u y
r a y c o n dot com
slash taste buds you're gonna save 15
on your recon order by raycon.com taste
buds buffy buffy buffy not talking
vampire slayer talking the bedroom
player
loving buffy man
how many of you spent sleepless nights
worrying about the impact the bedding
industry has on the environment
i know a lot of you have and i know a
lot of you just spent some sleepless
nights not being comfortable not being
cool being too hot whatever it is well
buffy is here with products made using
only sustainable recycled materials and
they're super soft okay they're gonna
get you into that bed uh this is as soft
as as you can get uh from anything on
the planet for your bedding okay their
latest product i mentioned being hot the
breeze comforter i mean entirely 100
from eucalyptus fiber and it regulates
your temperature i keeps you cool all
night long people i have one of these
i'm telling you i am a
habitual sweater at night particularly
this thing keeps me cool all night long
i was a above the covers guy because i
couldn't find a blanket that kept me
warm uh but not hot
uh and
i don't know if you've ever slept a
blood above the covers it's
it's you're out there you're exposed
okay we'll leave it at that thank you
buffy for the breeze comforter now i can
sleep underneath with no more night
sweats this is softer than cotton
so it's naturally going to soothe your
skin again earth friendly okay it's
hyperallergenic too that's the thing the
high thread count shuts out the dust and
the mold and the mites for a healthier
sleeping environment and it's cruelty
free there's no down feathers here so
you can try this comforter on your own
bed
for free
if you don't love it you return it at no
cost
please do it here's how you do it i want
you to go to buffy.co
and enter the promo code tastebuds
you're going to get 20 off your
comforter okay again buffy dot co
and enter the promo code taste buds
guess what you get 20 off your comforter
including the guarantee again buffy.co
enter the promo code taste buds 20 bucks
off that buffy comforter
no dude a little nemo's chocolate cake
square did you ever get one of those out
of a bodega oh yeah of course that's a
brownie though no it's not that's a
chocolate cake square see i little
nemo's are the best they're that's not a
brownie dude that's cake those are
advertisers chocolate cake
but i feel like if it's cut to a square
in my opinion that's what makes it
a brand
it's a different recipe it's a different
consistency and texture they're similar
but it's different
oh do they say mousse and pudding are
the same they're not there's a different
consistency by the way speaking of moose
i went into your bathroom you have
hairspray in your bathroom yeah what do
you use hairspray for sometimes to keep
my curls in place oh god i don't even
know why i'm friends with you
well that's fine i went to your bathroom
you got deodorant in there
why
you should just have flea repellent i
have tick repellent all over my house
but listen
listen what i'm saying is is chocolate
cake
my favorite version of it
and i i know it's low rent i mean i look
i scoffed to you about olive garden this
is low rent i don't care duncan hines or
betty crocker box chocolate cake i agree
with that when you make that in the oven
and you put that icing on out of that
little tin i agree
it's the grip i mean i could eat a whole
i could literally eat a whole one i have
to stop myself i have eaten a whole one
entenmann's chocolate cake with the
chocolate icing yeah my favorite
entermanns again i could eat a whole one
i decided yeah when i moved from la to
new york it was such a stressful move
and i was living with half furniture for
like two weeks
and i had no bed i just had this couch i
was sleeping on this couch and i was
surrounded with
just it was it was chaos because i i had
no furniture in this apartment no i'm
the first apartment when i first came
back i had nowhere to put anything so
it's just boxes around me and pile it
was horrible
and uh
i would wake up in the morning this
apartment had no windows it was so dark
wake up in the morning and i would
immediate i would sit up
and next to me every morning without
fail was a box of entement's ch a
chocolate cake and a bottle of red wine
that i had started the night before and
i would start drinking it and eating the
cake as soon as i woke up oh
as soon as i sat up dude that's that's
depression right there you probably was
you didn't even highlight that he was so
i was so depressed i hadn't slept on a
bed in two months because the way the
move was workers tried it and they took
my bed and whatever and the movers were
late it was brutal dude i was so
depressed and it was right coming up on
christmas wow it was brutal it was cold
the apartment was all dark but anyway
that's how much i love chocolate cake
that i'll eat it for breakfast with wine
during a depression yeah well chocolate
here listen i i it's one of those ones
where it's i'm defending cheesecake and
i'm happy to do that but it's hard to
like
it's almost like if you don't like
chocolate cake
it's like you know like when there's two
people like i don't trust people that
drink
which i find but i i don't trust people
that don't like chocolate cause like how
could you not like chocolate or
chocolate cake it's a little ridiculous
but if you put a gun to my head if you
put a gun to my head i would pick
cheesecake over chocolate cake because i
think cheap because here's the thing
here's why i like cheesecake so much
because i think like first of all i know
you could put whipped cream and all that
stuff on chocolate cake too but the
mixture of whipped cream and cheesecake
is so good the right cheesecake the
right cheesecake i mean like from a
diner hear me out yeah cause sometimes
like the regatta italian cheesecakes are
a lot like that like you know what i
made like i'm like all right these are
okay and it's too small of a piece but
dude a diner cheesecake there was this
diner on off queens boulevard called pop
steiner that they actually do comedy
shows at
shows there yeah but they had the best
cheesecake you've ever had in your life
it was creamy it was like junior's
cheesecake sometimes it's good sometimes
isn't but this diner like old-fashioned
diner cheesecake is just
fantastic
and dude for me whenever i hear cheese
i'm in i mean
i mean cheesecake for me
i agree i love a nice piece of
cheesecake the older i get the less of
it i can eat because i keep building up
this lactose intolerance which sucks oh
that sucks dude i know it sucks uh
i'm down to like three cheeses at this
point really yeah
what like
i can eat hard cheeses are you positive
you're lactose intolerant yeah dude milk
uh uh certain cheeses
um ice cream i eat it my my inner ear
starts itching really bad if i eat too
much i get a stomach ache and i throw up
yeah yeah here's how much i love
cheesecake i even though i eat bacon for
some reason just pork rib just skeeved
me out even though i know it's the same
pig here's here's what i'll tell you
with cheesecake i would literally eat
cheesecake made with somebody else's
breast milk i'd eat the whole thing
that's how much i love cheesecake that's
upsetting that's upsetting listen why is
that upsetting i'm telling you i love
cheese i say this about i'll say this
about cheesecake
it's great i love it first of all the
fact that you've mentioned putting
whipped cream on the fact that any of us
are putting toppings on cheesecake is
insane it's so fatty and so rich to
begin with the fact that cheesecake
factory has a whole menu yeah a flavor
infused she's it's a it's crap it's a
crime dude their menu is like it's like
a it's like when the government released
like a million pages on aliens that's
cheesecake's menu it's like it's not
like there's so many items to choose
it's just insane and not a healthy thing
on the menu the salads at cheesecake
factory have 1 600 calories it's wild
me and pat walsh when i lived in l.a we
would
we had to go to the movies all the time
because we had to watch movies for our
podcast we'll see you in hell to review
and there was at the americana there's a
there's a cheesecake factory right next
to the amc
and
we were always so depressed we would go
to the cheesecake factory and get
plastered at the bar in there that was
like our bar that was like our local bar
oh
so you wouldn't even need food you would
just get drunk at the cheese most of the
time we would just sit there and get
drunk they poured them heavy in there
so you got the drink on the rocks it was
like that their drinks were no joke that
might that might be the most degenerate
thing i've heard anybody say ever it was
you getting ripped at the cheesecake
factory that was great dude it was a
great time anyway but i'll say this
about cheesecake
when chocolate cake is bad
it's not great but it's pretty good
when cheesecake is bad
it is
bad
when it's bad
it's bad it's it almost has like
generous cheesecake with that when it
has like that key lime pie consistency
yes
it's so gross dude but here's the thing
here's here's but but i will agree with
you but i'll say but don't you want some
steaks in your food chocolate cake you
know like it's like pizza it's always
gonna the worst it's gonna be is ah but
it literally can also be so good that it
changes your life and that's what i like
about cheesecake is yes pound-for-pound
if you put out 100 pieces of chocolate
cake and 100 pieces of cheesecake more
pieces of chocolate cake would be better
than cheesecake but the amazing home run
hitting cheesecake beats the home run
hitting chocolate cake every time dude a
literally this is that is a straight up
salvo argument did you how much you
watching the show and did you cherry
pick his arguments before you came in
here i swear to god i swear i swear on
my nona which you know i never lie about
i've never seen other than the clips
homeless pimpos a second of taste buds
all right yeah that's fine i don't watch
hay babes so don't worry no but i don't
think we should be no no when am i
watching my friends
i don't support you
yeah why would i ever do that
uh that is a pound for pound salvo conor
argument if there ever was one really
yeah so that's what's up
he goes with that a lot but i think okay
but when i say i always go the opposite
direction i say if that many ducks need
to be in order for your thing to be
phenomenal we're talking
that is that is those stakes are too
high for me i need a workhorse food i
need a food that is going to be there
for me when i need to count on it if i
walk into a deli
okay and they got a refrigerated section
with desserts in it and they've got
individual slices in the plastic
containers which is not the best thing
right but if i'm really hankering for
something and it's 3 a.m and i got no
other choice and i see a piece of
cheesecake or a piece of chocolate cake
i'm grabbing the chocolate cake nine
times out of 10 i'm going to be
not just happy i'm going to think it's
delicious dude
and when that dice roll on that
cheesecake is a big this just tells me
everything i need to know about derosa
because and and i could apply it to the
times here's what it is dude chocolate
cake is corporate one percent and that's
what you want to be so bad even though
you're posing as a small business aka
cheesecake artist dude you have the look
of a cheesecake but the mind of a
chocolate cake you pig
you look like a cause cheesecake is arty
it's artsy it's a one-off
yeah it is already
so the new york post just wrote an
article article about him said he's
coming back so it's good yeah i'm happy
to hear that i miss shardy a lot i know
what sal would say in this argument he'd
say cheesecake is elegant girl next door
and chocolate cake is like attention
[ __ ] instagram thought no no chocolate
cake cake is corporate is corporate
business and cheesecake is small
business we're about supporting the
small business pimpy you know what i
would say in this argument cheesecake is
for your exclusive ritzy i want to look
down on the working man [ __ ]
business class of people and chocolate
cake is out there in the streets making
it happen every day making itself
accessible it's still riding the subway
every day that chocolate cake rides the
subway it takes the bus okay you're in
the back of a black uh uber black do it
with cheesecake cheesecake you're in the
cop car driving into the protesters eat
that cheese he's gonna do it i'm in the
streets with the signs passing out
slices of chocolate cake dude cheesecake
even when it loses it wins just like
donald trump
folks it's been a year of loss it's been
almost two years of loss we don't need
any more and that goes for the small
things too like your hair two out of
three men are experiencing some form of
hair loss by the time they're 35 years
old okay
more than 50 million men in the u.s
suffer from male pattern baldness and
there are only two fda approved
medications that can prevent
hair loss keeps offers both so let's
talk about keeps it's a convenient
service you get a virtual doctor who
will consultate you and send you the
medications straight to your door every
three months so you never have to leave
home prevention is key that's what keeps
is all about treatment can take four to
six months to see results so you're
going to want to act fast but when that
treatment works it's preventing further
hair loss keeps also has more five-star
reviews than any of its competitors that
goes a long way with me because i don't
care what some company's telling me to
buy i don't care what some companies
tell me to use i don't care what some
podcast host is telling me to use the
customer is key and the fact that
they've got all these five-star reviews
speaks leagues about them so if you're
ready to take some action to prevent
hair loss go to keeps.com
taste buds that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash taste buds you're gonna
get your first month of treatment for
free what do you get to lose here
k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash taste buds your first
month is free keeps.com taste buds
people
i love a good combo all right i love a
big bacon cheeseburger combo when i'm
out of drive through
i love a nice
strawberry chocolate vanilla neapolitan
combo back before i had a lactose
intolerance and could enjoy ice cream
and you know what else i like a combo of
my booze
let's talk fizzy for a second this is
the only option for you where you're
going to get hard sell sir
with
antioxidant vitamin c busy is bringing
you something unique
and it's delicious come on man it's
summer time we want to enjoy these
moments with a crisp refreshing bev some
hard sells like a vizzy watermelon and
it's made with real watermelon juice by
the way so that just makes it even
better okay
just in time for summer visi hard
seltzer has dropped this all
new watermelon variety packets hitting
shelves in july that's right now again
made with real watermelon juice and each
fizzy includes antioxidant vitamin c my
god what more can you ask for you're
drinking and you're helping and you're
healing
i like it anyway i really like the
watermelon i'm one of those weirdos that
um i hate actual watermelon but i love
watermelon flavored things that's a very
common
for some reason
love real bananas hate banana flavored
things
fizzy don't make a banana flavor please
banana drink we
but i love watermelon flavored drink and
vizzy's is delicious uh so upgrade your
hard seltzer today to vizi
only one place to buy it by the way
you're going to go to
busyheartseltster.com
tastebuds that's vizi v-i-z-z-y hard
seltzer dot com taste buds and if you
want to get updates on all the latest
flavor drops and more you can sign up
for emails at vizi
hard hardseltzer.com subscribe that's
vizzyhardselser.com
subscribe you must be 21.
yeah i mean dude you you can't you can't
deny
the king of let's let me let's let's let
me rephrase this the king of all cakes
okay i'm sorry the king of all desserts
in my opinion is cake
i'll agree with that
it out does pie it out does ice cream
yeah i agree with that the king of all
desserts is cake i agree
the king of all cakes
traditional cakes is chocolate cake
no little kid on his birthday classic
derosa thing sorry to say myself for the
third person i didn't mean to die but
you're gonna get one more and then i'm
leaving did i do it already yeah dude
you did it on hey babe no i didn't yes
you did dude you don't that's what a
monster you are you don't even realize
you're a tyrant
no i only did it because pimp said sal
that's a if sal was here he'd say that
okay
so i just was in that mindset anyway
and this is something i say a lot on
here but it is true it's true and
everybody gives me [ __ ] about it but
it's true no kid has ever said i want a
cheesecake for my birthday okay but i
thought this was an adult show i i
didn't know for all ages which is why we
don't swear
oh you guys don't swear either here no
we do oh they just bleep it i do think i
agree with that yeah like but see no no
no no no no no no see i disagree here's
why i just go with the kids i think so
you know i'm right no kid goes i want
cheesecake for my birthday but the king
of all cakes and is the birthday cake
but for the birthday which is golden
with vanilla top with vanilla floss
please any kid worth his salt wants a
chocolate cake for his birthday or white
icing on it to get a chocolate cake for
your birthday you know much more
expensive that is i think pound for
pound the average child throughout the
world is getting a birthday cake ice
cream cake
ice cream you want to talk expensive and
you want to bring ice cream cake dude
carvel ice cream cake it's like nine
bucks
you are nuts dude you are nuts
ice cream cake is the diamond birthday
cake
that is some special stuff dude look
pimp is trash from queens pimp what did
you have most birthdays growing up when
you were a little kid he's trash i'm
trash
ice cream cake see
that's what we did in the burrows dude
and i don't know what you guys did in
delaware county ice cream cake was a
rare bell ice cream cake ice cream cake
was a real special occasion for us but
also carvel was not common where i lived
oh what what did you have dairy queen
nah see dairy queen's a hot commodity
for us
ice cream cake was a real special thing
when they told us we were getting ice
cream cake it was like guess what kids
we got ice cream okay it was exciting
man dude i'll tell you once i vividly
remember to sit with my dad and my
stepmom on staten island and the
commercial came on for the dairy queen
blizzard and the closest dairy queen was
like 60 miles away in central jersey and
we drove there and did that on a first
saturday night we went and got dairy
queen blizzards
i never forget dude remember how easy it
was at that age to be entertained
and then i think why were my i like i
remember how entertained i was by the
simplicity that that age i think why
were my parents entertained yeah why
weren't my parents like bro we got to
hit a bar
like this this sucks well i never
realized like until i've gotten older
like literally dude every saturday
morning like if i had basketball
practice or something like that you know
when i had to wake up early my mom was
like all right you know chris take the
trash down before you go and every
saturday morning
like clockwork i would take down the
trash and there'd be two polished off
bottles of white zinfandel in the
garbage bag and i just thought like
that's what adults did but i didn't
realize it was my mom on a friday night
was like i gotta sit here with my dumb
kid so i might as well crack up good for
her some sutter home wipes in and she
used to talk to her friend barbara to
like three o'clock in the morning they
would die laughing but i just thought it
was like mom's what a per it was moms my
mom was always talking on the phone
until late laughing at her after
drinking wines and [ __ ] by herself she
didn't drink but my mom was a foodie so
she ate stuff yeah yeah yeah a lot of
desserts and stuff through the night but
i mean my dad used to go into the
basement dude my dad used to go into our
basement and smoke cigars in the in a
windowless basement oh my god
in a windowless basement dude while he
worked over a buzzsaw oh like this is
you want to talk about a man that needs
to get out of it my god and you were
upstairs thinking about different types
of art to hang on the wall god he must
hate you
he's like i want i just want my kid to
come down here with a power tool and a
cigar and he keeps coming down with
different album covers and i'll tell you
what okay what my dad would have eaten
if i went down there chocolate cake no
because he's a real man no dude you're
are you kidding me you're a ginzo from
philly that i guarantee you your mom and
dad would pick cheesecake i'll say this
compliment to both
nothing beats either of these cakes with
a cup of black coffee as your dessert
have you got a cup of black coffee with
either one of these you're good it is a
grand slam dessert here's what i've done
multiple times you ready for this you
ready for this and this is 100 sure i
don't have doc
video documents of it but i've done this
multiple times i like to drink my coffee
black except when i'm having dessert
multiple times i've taken a piece of
dessert and put it in the coffee as a
creamer and i've done that multiple
times with cheesecake i think sal has
admitted to the same thing what is wrong
with the two staten island
are you from staten island well half my
life my dad i grew up and went to all
high schools in queens but i could
arguably say i have a lot of friends on
half my life i spent on staten island
because my dad lived in new dork what a
that was the name of the place what a
fence to straddle bay ridge and staten
island yeah jesus dude you should have
to live in that river that separates
them
i'll tell you what i am going to get
tattooed on my body before it's said and
done is the verrazano bridge oh my god
that's our skyline all right all right
would you get if i paid for it would you
get it i swear to god i would
if i paid for it would you get a tattoo
of the verrazano bridge
what part of my body
can i choose the part of my body yeah
but but yeah but you can't get it like
on your upper yeah no no i want to get
it i want to show it off yeah yeah but i
don't have to get on like my forearm or
something oh no where would you get it
maybe in the middle over here
all right if i pay for it will you get
it yeah i will i swear to god you swear
to god i swear to god i swear to god
i'll get the vows on a bridge tattooed
on my body all right pimp
we're doing that for the patreon done no
pressure patreon is coming very soon
i'll do it that's it all right i'm
paying for it yup i'm in all right
that's it it's on camera you heard it
here first pimp where we at time was
35 minutes oh wow all right so let's go
let's go to the phones as we like to
around this point in the show on the
phone hear what people say what are
people saying
cheesecake is just congealed blob of
crab it's way too rich one bite and you
could feel the diabetes kicking in great
point chocolate cake
with icing is the bomb just the right
amount of sweetness again
you you okay but my all right my yes yes
yes yes
dude that's so oh my god i'm the kid on
the left
just a fat disgust the thing is with
chocolate cake though is yes but it's
the same amount of sugar content i don't
think chocolate cake is healthier than
cheesecake it's a hundred percent
healthier than cheesecake the the
healthier is the wrong term
neither are healthy in any way shape or
form but chocolate a slice of chocolate
cake is far less bad for you than a
slice of
cheesecake all right fine whatever i'm
so hungry now chocolate cake is for sad
drunk people after a breakup cheesecake
is a delicacy to be enjoyed simply do
you want to be depressed or happy i'll
say this too about chocolate cake and
it's an argument i'll make
the beauty of chocolate cake is you're
getting some of the bitterness and the
hints of the dark chocolate versus the
sweet of the milk chocolate versus the
dash of salt which brings in some savory
it's just a it's just a perfect flavor
balance cheesecake is one flavor it is a
creamy cheese flavor and it's very good
but if you're
in for a penny in for a pound with
cheesecake man i like dark chocolate
cake over anything do you like dark
chocolate i like it i like it all but i
like it straight up i love a chocolate
cake the light brown chocolate cake with
a dark icing in it and a rich icing you
know like i love it what's the best
chocolate cake in new york city in your
opinion i swear to god dude nothing is
ever going to top the box cakes from the
supermarket for me that's just the best
those are just incredible to me i agree
with you dude
i'm i'm on a diet right now and i'm
thinking about it right now i'm saying
so keep saying you're on a diet can i
set it off air no you're not gonna know
what you're talking about okay you've
said you've said that you're on a diet
now ten times since i've been here
you're you're gonna ruin it i guarantee
you by next week we could get drink
we're gonna be drinking we're gonna be
eating your sandwiches at the stands i'm
gonna get let me at least get a week
into it how about that
if you can get if you literally dude can
get 14 days in a diet if you can get 14
days into your diet document then i'll
give you 200.
and i'm gonna you're an honest guy i'm
gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna rely on your
integrity for this and trust you 100
that you don't get drunk one night and
i'm talking about diet you're not eating
bread or sugar if you eat bread or sugar
in 14 days you lose
all right
i'll give you 200 bucks all right fine i
don't think he's gonna do it do you
think he i'll do it this is easily this
is the honor system here we're going to
do it
he's not he he won't lie joe i'll give
him that i'll do it easily he's a piece
of pig
but i'm not a liar there's not a lot he
isn't a liar
i will do that easily okay all right
yeah uh you're gonna need some drinks
for chocolate cake because it leaves
your mouth dry like the sarah desert i
don't agree with that at all chocolate
cake cake is a little black dress of
cakes oh very nice oh that's hot that's
very hot
you know what
pimp
that might be our winner today even
though it's got nothing to do with the
whole thing
just shout with a gun
[Music]
that is a great that's a great photoshop
too because it looks like an actual
picture
all right so i mean pam put up put a pin
in that one that might be our winner
today so what do you pick one winning
tweet yeah oh good uh cheesecake and
that's on rose blanche dorothy and
sophia all the girls brendan i love the
golden girl so much i can't argue with
you on that
they serve sad pieces of chocolate cake
in prisons
as if it's a congratulations you're
incarcerated
that's another contender for winner yeah
uh chocolate cake is the most basic
[ __ ] drunk mom trying to redeem her
son's birthday after she's failed him as
a too worthy too worried too wordy
are we serious cheesecake needs a viagra
in the form of a sauce a fruit or an
assistant for its limp dung
chocolate is a mother
chocolate chocolate is mother chocolate
needs nothing just whips it out takes
your mouth
down a flavor all right that that one
obviously wins that one wins that
obviously wins our winner is steve levy
follow stephen
sportsnot1124
who won the actual poll though where
we're going to find out oh okay we do
that at the end yeah so
uh dude how much better is pimp getting
at spelling have you noticed the
improvement on spelling not much but but
better but better he's got a long hill
to clap yeah
spelling in white stone queens no it's
wild he'll spell like he'll you'll be
like pimp google pumpkin pie and i'll
spell it with like a y in it or
something yeah yeah and then you'll be
like
pimp uh see how old armand asante is
it'll
[Music]
but he can like literally like tap into
like the voting system like he can out
tap like you know like get through like
the the cia services
yes
but by the way biden who's from
pennsylvania would pick cheesecake uh
all right let's go to the top you know
fat trump would pick chocolate cake oh i
know you would that's a fat slob
oh
god a lot dude
56.43 really wow by a little bit by the
way this episode doesn't count to our
poll
no it it well how does it not count the
sound's not even here yeah but i don't
but i didn't pick the the tweets but
sal's not here do you think this guy by
the way sal said he's uh considering one
year-end punishment uh to eat a
deep-fried tarantula
really remember it happened on hey babe
oh yeah
would you if if you lost the record for
the year would you eat a deep-fried
tarantula
is it safe
yeah they do make sure some country we
found oh yeah some country you found
yeah dude yeah okay
guess what some country you found is
coronavirus came from
uh i i i maybe i'd have to have a doctor
telling me it's safe get dr steve to
tell you it's safe i mean
what am i doing i get advice from a man
call me back hey dr steve said about
kronos like joe stop how many votes well
20
899 votes is that the most votes you
guys have had what's the most votes you
guys are hundred thousand hundred
thousand
it went kitkat snickers went viral like
trendy kitkat picked it up and it yeah
it started trending it was crazy and who
won that one kitkat or snickers shower
one with kitkat i couldn't believe the
kick had anything
but it pummeled snickers i thought in
popularity alone snickers was going to
cause
no you know why you know why one i don't
know if you guys may discuss this
because there's a big pretty healthy
part of population that doesn't like
caramel or nuts yeah but everybody likes
chocolate and wafers so you know
so man humble pie today i lose
cheesecake 56.2 to chocolate cake 43.8
percent we always end by you saying i
still love you
i still love you i love you too
they coming to the mic talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
they like two fools gonna fight but only
one food can be right taste buds man
yeah they're coming to the mic i'm
talking taste buds